what do you think about bitcoin right
now in terms of like the high degree of
volatility right when you see all this
volatility do you think that people we
we saw the grayscale bitcoin investor
study shows that 55 or so of people who
owned bitcoin today first time they ever
bought it was in 2021 which is pretty
incredible statistic yeah well it
doesn't seem like that many of them are
actually selling they've weathered six
drawdowns of over 20 one over 50 uh one
over 40 three over 30. like that's a lot
of volatility for a single year and
they're still here i mean it's it's no
different to bitcoin's last 13 years
anyway right like
since when has bitcoin not been volatile
like since when has um i mean and the
thing is we just need to be careful
about how we define volatility right
volatility in relationship to what um
because bitcoin in its own
sphere is actually not volatile
bitcoin's the most unvolatile thing that
exists today you know it no one changes
the code base like it takes four years
to roll out tap root like
bitcoin is the definition of
anti-volatile
but
in
the i guess the madness of the crowds
which is people discovering how to value
this thing called bitcoin uh there is
volatility in perception there is
volatility in subjective valuation there
is volatility in how people understand
appreciate and like
um
form an opinion with respect to what
bitcoin is valued for themselves so so
that's volatile um but bitcoin itself
it's it's not volatile like it's it's
perfectly stable it's perfectly pristine
it's perfectly
tick-tock next block
and i think that's what people need to
separate in their heads so if you've got
a bunch of mindless idiots running
around selling their bitcoin for
basically
fake paper money issued by you know
central bankers
you should rejoice and you should
acquire as much of that as you can like
because if you stop for a minute and
just step back
like volatility is inherent
to things like central banks because
what do they do they change their mind
every day or every week you know first
inflation's transient no it's not you
know now it's because of people didn't
get vaccinated or then tomorrow it's
because of global climate change
tomorrow it's because you know mass
toxic masculinity like that's volatility
like volatility and opinion volatility
and policy volatility and everything
whereas bitcoin is just it's not it's
fundamentally not volatile bitcoin's the
only heartbeat that exists in the world
today that we can point to and know that
it's there
hasn't changed it's still what it is
it's backwards compatible for 13 years
that's perfection
and it's the relationship between a
volatile world and a perfectly pristine
manifestation of like a heartbeat
that connection is volatile and the
alpha that we get out of it is we
understand that bitcoin's not volatile
and by the time the rest of the world
understands it then you know
the the when the when the relationship
between the old and the new is severed
at the point where we don't need the old
then you know you don't notice the
volatility anymore